this worldview was summed up by no less
an intellect
last night than mark ruffalo at the zoom
golden globe awards i did not know that
the golden globe awards were
going on until i saw this stupid mark
ruffalo headline trending
they didn't really hold the golden
globes this was this actually was just
on zoom these people just zoomed in from
their
homes and accepted the award on a little
tiny screen hypotheticus that
and ruffalo one of the most insufferable
people in hollywood decided to
use his acceptance to
give a theological diatribe
about our filial relationship to the
earth we have a dying mother just like
the mother in our story
she's mother earth and we must come to
balance with her
and honor her and she'll heal too
so let's be courageous together guys and
let's
let's turn let's turn the page on the
cruel past of this nation
the good news is inclusion and justice
and care for mother earth is breaking
out
everywhere the godly light of decency
is breaking through the hideous
dark storm we've been living through we
are all in this together we are the ones
we've been waiting for
so let's do this now i love you
oh where to begin first of all
our mother the earth
the earth is not my mother the earth is
a rock floating in space
that i like very much i really i love
the earth
i think it's great it provides a very
nice home for me
the earth is not my mother when people
say the earth
is our mother they are espousing a
religious point of view just as i might
say that my mother is the holy church
just as i might say in another sense
that my mother is
mary the mother of god just as i might
say that
so too some some crazy lib might say
that the earth is our mother
if the earth is our mother we have a
filial responsibility to her
and on the other side of that if the if
the if we are the children of the earth
then we're just kind of like dirt right
that's all that's kind of all we are
we don't really have the higher
spiritual faculties
that say christianity or even other
theistic religions
would put on us but the religious way
he's talking is even more explicit he
says he
keeps coming back he says the good news
is
inclusion and diversity the good news is
the good news is the good news is the
gospel
okay when when people who don't have
this kooky
live religion when people who have like
who are christians
say the good news is what's the good
news the good news is that
the earth i'm not the child of a rock
that uh
the i'm actually uh a child of god i'm a
man made in the image of god
uh god sends his only begotten son
christ to die for us and and uh we can
be part of the body of christ and christ
can live in us
and redeem mankind uh if we
if we accept him through faith and we
under
sort of understand this kind of or we
grant this kind of
world view this relationship of us
to the son of god who is god in the
triune god in the godhead
and therefore we have a special
relationship to creation and to the
creator okay right that's one
version of the good news if you're a
christian
but if you don't believe any of that
stuff then what is the good news is
diversity and equity and inclusion
which which is treated as a religion
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]
you